this morning on the dish restaurateur Hollis well
Silverman she's behind not just one but three new
establishments in the Capitol Hill Neighborhood
of Washington DC we visited Silverman for a meal
and a chat about how her creative approach could
perhaps change the culinary industry as a whole
walk into this space on Capitol Hill and no
matter your taste move or degree of hunger
you've got choices there's the Italian inspired
La Colina a cocktail bar known as the wells
and then the duck and the peach a seasonal Twist
on New American Cuisine coined with love so the
peach is a nickname for my daughter and the duck
is a nickname for my old black lab so ravioli to
finish 62. for a restaurant tour Hall as well
Silverman it's a take on the ultimate dinner
party I wanted to do something that was familiar
was a little bit nicer than maybe people could
prepare at home but not too pretentious so really
approachable we wanted to create kind of small
intimate spaces but turning an old school in
her neighborhood into a passion project wasn't
exactly her wish come true restaurants are an
insane business so most of them fail I never
wanted to open a restaurant but you say that with
a smiling thing well I feel like in the world and
especially after the pandemic you have to have a
smile on your face with construction starting in
early 2020 the first concept open within a year
the other two followed in mid-2021 there was an
opportunity to open these spaces and I knew
that if I let someone else do this I would be
not happy three restaurants virtually in
the same spot what you know how did you
pull this off uh with a great team a great team
she says that delivers great food like kampachi
Crudo with cucumber and avocado puree carrots
over sheep's alabne or yogurt winter squash
rice made with bear Beret and Ethiopian spice
blend and topped with pumpkin seeds and shallot
it hits on the second bite and Silverman's
favorite must-have on the menu rotisserie
chicken with cilantro Zug roasted chicken is my
love language and why is that whenever anyone
needs something or you drop a meal or someone
has a baby you're having a hard time I typically
roast a chicken and I give it to people got it
because a roast chicken is a true sign of love
and deliciousness a lot of hallways in this joint
we do have a lot of hallways in this joint leading
to many things many many things it starts with
the floor plan three cons steps that actually
share just one kitchen well nobody's supposed to
know that so technically it's two restaurants in
a bar from the guest perspective but I knew from
my experience that in order to have a successful
business you need volume so I designed something
that I felt people needed living here for so long
and being married and then without kids married
with dog married with kids with the stroller
without the stroller and understanding that
you need a little bit of everything push your
dough on top and kind of get your fingers get
the divots in executive chef Katarina petinito
gave me a lesson on the art of making three cheese
ravioli oh wow I'm getting the hang of this yeah
that looks great and offered her take on the
company line I would say she's probably one
of the greatest people I've worked for she's very
passionate about making an environment that's safe
and encouraging for everyone to be in pattonito
says the kitchen is built on efficient see we do
all like the right things we're recycling we're
composting we're using sustainable products we're
working with local farms and agriculture to make
sure that we're bringing in as local ingredients
and seasonal like hyper seasonal ingredients and
Silverman threads her intention through everything
like an all women wine program and executive team
we're trying to change the game we're trying to
really create a place where people feel welcome
everyone feels welcome she got her start in San
Diego in Northern California with a degree in
Hospitality management later transferring to
DC with her Navy husband where she landed in the
view of Chef Jose Andres Jose is an amazing leader
but he's also an amazing team member so he knows
how to build a team he knows how to look at not
only food but look at beverages look at design
look at all the things and figure out how to
make it better and that's something that not many
people do she would become Chief Operating Officer
of his think food group and over 10 years nearly
tripled his staff expanding his local brand into
a national Empire it enabled him to take on big
problems like world hunger Silverman is tackling
big issues too on a smaller scale we're tackling
tipping I think that how tipping started is not
great I think that it leads unfortunately to a lot
out of unhealthy cultures and work environments
so we do a service charge instead we pay people
a higher hourly rate and paying people with their
worth Fosters creativity as we saw with pastry
chef and ice cream Queen Rochelle Cooper and
say we have a lot of fun with it the team gets
creative and comes up with great flavors like
the dough ball trouble oh my gosh the diet
goes out the window here experimentation is
the spirit of the wells where jyn is front and
center oh okay you got me at the Ice Cube well
it's really a good cocktail is about the ice
and then we just add a bunch of fresh Citrus
and Botanicals and herbs and spices to bring
out the flavor of the gym wow when do you open
running these three concepts is a labor of
love Silverman doesn't shy away from you know
I can't change certain things but like this is
what I can do so people can come in they know
that they're going to have a great time they
feel like they can enjoy someone across the
table from them and that's how I can hopefully
put a little bit more joy into people's lives
love the cocktail bar we couldn't tell even though
I'm on dry January I had to taste and this is one
of her fascinating Blends it's a classic curb
take on the gin and tonic with juniper berries
lemon lime so yummy I love that what was the ice
cream again don't double dough uh no sugar-free
January yeah no no it was unbelievable good
stuff it all looked delicious yes it did